well the Prime Minister and I have made
a promise to the British people to stop
the boats we are committed to delivering
on that promise we've got an
unsustainable problem that we need to
fix and whilst of course we are
disappointed with the decision today we
will be putting in an application to
seek permission to appeal the Judgment
very very swiftly
how swiftly is that likely to be do you
think well the court itself has asked
for any applications to be made by the
6th of July so we'll be adhering to that
timetable because the clock's ticking
you talked about the deportations to
Rwanda being in the summer I think
September is your latest Target where
does this all leave the illegal
migration bill because you're suffering
defeat after defeat on that in the House
of Lords now you've lost in the court of
appeal isn't the whole policy unraveling
not at all our bill is absolutely
essential as a an element in fixing this
problem it will allow us to detain and
remove those who arrive here illegally
the problem is out of control 45 000
people arrived to illegally last year
it's costing the British taxpayer six
million pounds a day in hotel
accommodation that is why the British
people want us to fix this problem the
system is rigged against them and that's
why we're doing everything within our
power to fix the system change our laws
and stop the boats but your own
department has said it's going to cost
about 100 up to 170 000 pounds per
Asylum Seeker to deport them that's on
top of the massive legal bills you're
facing it's not really value for money
for the taxpayer is it well we are
currently spending as I say six million
pounds a day on Hotel accommodation
three billion pounds a year on servicing
our Asylum costs those costs are under
sustainable and the Prime Minister and I
have made it clear that we will do
whatever it takes to stop the boats and
fix this problem the decision today as
I've said is disappointing we
respectfully disagree with the court
judgment but it's important to note that
there are some elements upon which we
were successful in the decision and that
actually Rwanda we believe is a safe
country we have a groundbreaking
world-leading partnership with Rwanda
I've been to Rwanda very recently I've
seen the arrangements in place there are
robust assurances there is independent
monitoring Rwanda has an extensive track
record of supporting a hundred thousand
migrants and refugees so there are good
grounds for progressing with this policy
and I have every confidence in it who do
you blame for these setbacks is it Lefty
lawyers the labor party the House of
Lords or the blob
well the system is rigged against the
British people it's as simple as that
that's why we're changing the laws
through our illegal migration bill
that's why we are rolling out a
groundbreaking partnership with Rwanda
which we believe is lawful with a with a
country that we believe is safe so we
need to change the system we need to
change our laws that's how we're going
to stop the boats what's your latest
estimate of when they might the
deportations might start obviously for
that to happen you've got to win in the
Supreme Court what's your latest
prediction of when those deportations
might start well we will defer to the
timetable set by the
that is in their power power and we will
abide by any timeline they set this year
next year you'd have to ask the the
judges and the court for the timeline
but I do know in the summary judgment
issue today uh uh a a reference to doing
it as swiftly as possible was made by
the judges and uh as I said we'll we'll
defer to any timeline that the judges
sent